kubernetes is amazingly powerful but if
you're just getting started it might
also seem amazingly complicated
so let's learn how to debug applications
running on kubernetes
hi caslin thanks for coming by i've been
learning a lot about kubernetes from you
you know about pods and services
containers and more and they mostly work
pretty well but what i do when things
aren't working oh that's a great
question
learning how to debug kubernetes is very
useful especially because applications
on kubernetes can grow so large
it can be very difficult to know what's
going on in your system at any given
time
exactly if i was just doing everything
manually and only had a few instances
i'd know how and where to look for the
information i need with kubernetes
abstracting away the infrastructure
behind the application i don't even know
where to start
well let's start with what you do know
how do you currently debug kubernetes
the cube ctl command line tool is some
useful tooling i've been using
i found them using cube ctl-dash help
but my favorites so far
cube ctl describe cubesat logs and cube
ctl get with the dash o flag
how do you use those well i use qctl
explain whenever i come across a new api
object that i don't know
what's especially nice about it is how i
can dig into the documentation of
specific fields too
so it's like a one-stop command line
shop for defining objects
cubesatl logs is useful because it lets
me see what's happening inside of a pod
it logs events from containers and
stores them so i can easily access them
then i use the trusty cube steel
described to look at pots dates and
events
that's a great start keepsee tail
described can tell you a lot
for instance if a pod is pending that
could mean you have insufficient
resources that prevent the pod from
getting scheduled onto a node
so maybe in that case i could delete
another pod or create a new node to make
space
yeah that might be a good way to handle
it another state a pod can be in is
the waiting state oh i have seen that
yeah that happens when a pod has been
scheduled onto a node but it can't run
for instance maybe the image can't be
pulled
so even though there's space to run the
app it just won't work
what about other cases like if there's
space to run the app and the image is
working
but the app itself is broken i'm not
sure how to debug that
for cases like that cubectl exec
is your friend oh let me look that up
cubectl exact
lets me execute a command in a container
or even open an interactive shell in the
container
wow that's useful so if you needed to
dig around
inside of your application maybe to see
where files are being stored or what
quartz are accessible inside the
container
exec is a really useful tool for that
okay so to summarize depending on the
state my pot is in whether it's pending
waiting or otherwise running but somehow
failing that determines what my issue
might be
yes and by using logs the exec command
and other very simple commands you can
generally find out enough information to
troubleshoot your application
wow thanks again to chasm for always
dropping knowledge
in this episode we learned a lot about
debugging kubernetes application
for more information check out the links
in the description below
[Music]